on a donc Miss Alsace Camille c'est dira
donc ça c'est sa photo officielle elle
porte de magnifiques sandalettes chez
Sarenza.com
et une Europe rouge carmin c'est Miss
Alsace qui ont fait sa favorite si vous
dites OUI ou NON d'accord merci très
bien en tout cas moi je trouve très
jolie et Camille tu es étudiante en
école de commerce sache que j'ai fait un
BTS
actions
Galvez Soto sa photo officielle est là
magnifique Aquitaine qui en fait ça
favorite non personne Oriane Galvez
surtout tu es maquilleuse sache que j'ai
fait un cap maquillage
tu veux me contacter avec un bar le
risque non mais c'est vrai si tu me
parles je mets Maybelline ou un truc
comme ça tu sais où me trouver
Miss Auvergne Alicia la DVD alors
personne elle a 20 ans elle est
étudiante en management international
Alicia si tu nous regardes sache que
j'ai énormément voyager j'étais encore
sur le Poitou-Charentes la semaine
dernière
on a Lara le Breton qui est Miss
Bourgogne c'est fou c'est comme Gérard
Lenorman qui n'a jamais habitant en
Normandie
se passe des trucs incroyable
breton qui infirmière sache que mon père
est médecin donc je connais bien le
corps médical voilà qui ont fait ça
favorite non c'est les photos
officielles c'est les vrais comme on dit
les vrais tetés voilà les vrais toxiques
Enora morale Miss Bretagne j'adore la
Bretagne
elle est étudiante en imagerie médicale
sache que je travaillais dedans dans un
centre de radiologie
donc Miss France aura forcément des
points communs
toujours pas et ben en tout cas elle est
très belle moi je trouve attention Miss
centre Val de Loire Coraline l'oral
allez étudiante en géographie et tu
tombes bien Coraline puisque j'étais
encore la semaine dernière au Brésil à
Madrid
et c'est vrai que je suis spécialiste
géographie et j'ai trois Atlas chez moi
et j'ai une map monde donc je pense que
tu ne peux que t'amuser à mes côtés elle
a 23 ans Coraline est-ce que quelqu'un
fait sa favorite personne pour l'instant
si la séquence ne vous intéresse
voilà j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une vie jeune famille
que je monte quoi des jeunes filles ça
fait 20 minutes que personne se
manifeste donc je dois bien mais vous me
dites les choses et puis je prends mes
petites noix je prends mes clics mais
claques et mes clic-clacent et je me
barre voilà 37 c'est ça alors Miss
Champagne-Ardenne
je te dirai la même chose
tu connais docteur Hanouna mon papa et
donc je pense qu'on a pas mal de choses
à se dire notamment sur la maladie de
Schutz
les symptômes c'est quand on oublie
qu'on a une meuf
[Rires]
c'est tu vois donc c'est la maladie de
Schwitz voilà
donc j'oublie voilà donc on peut en
parler
c'est chez moi la Champagne
aussi et toi parce que c'est toi tu vas
voter pour elle donc c'est bon
je la mets je te l'avais de côté enfin
soleil
on amène jamais sa saucisse à Strasbourg
on va passer à Miss Corse Oriane Meloni
et sur déconner j'ai l'impression d'être
à la rentrée des classes Oriane Meloni
rien de lui tu pars avec les 4e de B est
avec Madame mouchtar elle est intuite
elle est étudiante infirmière également
étudiant infirmière je pourrais te
parler également à toi de la maladie de
switch
oui j'aime bien moi alors donc c'est
votre favoris ouais génial elle a 22 ans
Oriane Meloni la Corse pour Benjamin
Castaldi Castaldi qui veut encore passer
des vacances à l'oeil tout simplement et
comme il a des fondements des amis
corses qui nous regardent ils se disent
s'ils peuvent me faire gratuitement la
location l'année prochaine ça serait pas
mal avec quelle image Flavie Barlin
elle s'appelle Flavie c'est Miss Côte
d'Azur
elle a 19 ans elle est également
étudiante en médecine les gars c'est pas
Miss France ils vont ils vont ils vont
ouvrir un hôpital comme une clinique
sans déconner donc alors Flavie barque
là oui c'est moi c'est bon
[Rires]
j'ai liké une de ces photos sur
Instagram elle a pas réagi c'est ce
qu'on appelle fuis-moi je te suis suis
moi je te fous
vous êtes atteint également de la
maladie de switch
consiste à oublier qu'on a une meuf mais
ta meuf
je crois que tu as pas oublié
étudiante en mode et Dieu sait que
la mode c'est ma vie quoi Marion Navarro
Miss Franche-Comté que j'adore et qui a
je le dis elle a liké des photos de ma
personne
je le dis Miss Franche-Comté j'adore les
gens francs j'adore le comté le fromage
donc je pense que voilà on est fait pour
se rencontrer pour quel type de photo la
liké c'était une photo de moi
non non je sais pas j'ai pas regardé
vous savez je ne regarde pas je ne suis
pas là-dedans je ne suis pas là-dedans
elle a liké une photo de moi tu trouves
pas
la télé
elle s'appelle Marion Navarro exactement
favorite bah oui respecte
indirect ah Shaina Robin 20 ans Miss
Guyane
je les mets en deux mains pas mal très
belle aussi King j'ai mis en deux mois
en deux d'accord bah on te demande la
une mais tu nous diras tu me feras tout
ton classement quand tu auras le temps
et pour l'instant on a quand même une
émission à faire donc là on va dire que
tu nous fais chier mais presque allez
Miss
Île-de-France Adèle Bonamour étudiante
en école de commerce elle a 18 ans elle
aime la vie elle aime la plage
alors NON MERCI ah Cameron Vallières
étudiante en marketing 23 ans
Delphine
donc c'est Miss Languedoc alors c'est
une ancienne
elle est spécialiste des Miss ah je vous
le dis non mais alors elle se trompe
jamais elle est tout aussi belle sur ses
photos que sur Instagram parce que ces
photos là vous le voyez ça met pas
vraiment
le fond n'est pas beau le maquillage est
très très léger c'est les photos
officielles c'est pas possible
alors Miss Limousin Salomé Maud diplômé
d'un master en management des achats
alors je te le dis j'adore acheter
ça devrait coller entre nous elle a 23
ans regardez là voilà elle aime la vie
et elle aime les le soleil
25 ans chargé de conformité dans le
secteur de l'investissement écoute moi
aussi je ne sais pas ce que tu fais ça
moi aussi je donc j'adore investir la
raison Sarah c'est mon coup de cœur moi
ouais alors c'est votre coup de cœur
alors c'est donc vous la choisissez oui
tout à fait merci on reviendra vers vous
ultérieurement Axel René 21 ans étudiant
ton gioscien c'est planétologie c'est ma
deuxième favorite merci Monsieur
donc oui alors NON MERCI MERCI on
l'embrasse ah kinésithérapeute Florence
de mortier Miss Pyrénées
à personne c'est pas c'est la mienne
c'est pas la mienne elle est ravissante
alors c'est votre c'est votre favorite
qui n'a rien à voir avec l'animateur
elle est aussi charmante allez allez
je mets de côté
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un peu votre délire je mets de
côté mon délire là je parle en tant que
pronostiqueur Perrine prunier et
j'envoie son ami mon frère Richard
pommier
23 ans étude en droit c'est Miss
Normandie Miss Normandie merci vous
découvrez les photos officielles des
missions à 20h47
Océane Le Goff il y en a pour 26 ans
diplômés en gestion et commerce
Océane Le Goff Le Goff
Océane très joli très sympa elle aime la
vie elle aime le soleil et ma Guilbert
et magibert 20 ans et ma Guilbert 20 ans
merci Bérénice Legendre 26 ans Miss
Picardie
alors il y a un truc merci mais personne
marine Pollet marine Pollet marine
Pollet tu suis tes petits camarades s'il
te plaît
je viens de me faire le maillot
oui ça c'est moi j'ai choisi
Poitou-Charentes Royan un peu de
chauvénisme très bien et puis elle est
magnifique regarde très bien bah merci
ben c'est sympa de t'avoir donc Shanna
Goyon et qui en fait n'est autre que
Chantal Goya
1830 bachelière
c'est une contrepette et on embrasse
également bien sûr son cousin Shanna
tova
bonne année à lui alors Provence Miss
Provence Shanna Goyon non merci
bachelière également elle a 18 ans elle
aime la vie
je mets de côté
Miss Réunion et je choisirai ensuite ma
favorite Esther Coutin Miss Rhône-Alpes
présentes en doctorat d'expertung
attention Chiara fontaine Chiara
fontaine 20 ans étudiant en psychologie
Miss Roussillon je mets de côté
Inès Tessier Inès Tessier je l'ai vu non
non mais non étudiante en
cinématographie j'ai encore revu hier le
cinquième élément
est une autre cinématographique très
sympa à 19 ans elle aime la vie elle
aime le soleil et Renou
tout et Java on l'avait oublié la
dernière fois Miss Tahiti alors Miss
Tahiti voilà elle est magnifique voilà
j'ai vos favoris alors j'ai tout mélangé
donc je ne sais pas qui
je peux vous dire que pour moi moi ma
favorite je choisis et je le dis haut et
fort Marion Marie Boutou Miss Réunion
voilà donc
les gars
c'est pas moi qui décide on va dire
qu'elle va être Miss France on dirait
qu'elle dit on dirait que je viens de
dire que c'était
ma première dauphine et Daniel Moreau